hangang Somali cap Emilia abs-cbn signed
off for what may be the last time just
before 8 o'clock on Tuesday night
this is abs-cbn channel 2 now forced
affair by a cease and desist order
issued by the Philippine government but
journalists at the largest media network
here remain defiant you know Ana
phenomena have complied with all the
requirements and we did not violate any
law abs-cbn failed to get Congress
approval for its license renewal
Congress is blaming the national
telecommunications agency which
previously made the commitment to issue
a provisional license activists say this
is the gravest assault on press freedom
under the current administration they
also described this is a clear case of
political harassment against a network
that has become the pillar of Philippine
democracy president rodrigo duterte has
repeatedly threatened abs-cbn in the
past saying that the network didn't
broadcast his political campaigns during
the 2016 presidential election president
rodrigo duterte spokesman says the
president hasn't had a say in the
closure decision and he remains neutral
rights groups say duterte often treats
journalists with contempt the online
news portal Rattler and the national
newspaper the Philippine Daily Inquirer
have been threatened with closure to the
network says the closure order threatens
the livelihoods of at least 11,000
workers management have been given 10
days to appeal the order and Congress
has promised to debate the license
renewal issue as soon as possible
marami puppet are among a Hungarian we
want to do more for our country and for
the Filipinos we can't give up together
we need to get through this crisis but
it's not the first time the network has
been forcibly shut down in 1972 former
President Ferdinand Marcos
order disclosure when he placed the
entire country under martial law its
owner was jailed and the network
remained affair for 14 years until the
People Power Revolution toppled the
Marcos dictatorship in 1986
critics say history may be repeating
itself Jamel Allen Dogg and Al Jazeera
Manila